hello everyone and Merry Christmas
everyone I know it's a bit late for a
Christmas video but it's it's been crazy
all day and I barely managed the time to
make this one as it is this time it will
not be a game it's a puzzle like the one
we had on last Christmas I think I
didn't have any puzzles before yeah
before last year's Christmas but it's a
really enjoyable puzzle it's I found it
on chess base calm and they've they
received a puzzle from pal Benko it's a
nice Christmas puzzle as you can see
this is supposed to be a Christmas tree
and it's really just a fun puzzle so I I
do hope you enjoy it but before we get
to the puzzle and what the puzzle is all
about as you can see there were usually
you will see a photo or two you know of
some famous chess players or or perhaps
mr. hoodie guy now there is a youtube
can promote chess so what does this mean
well some of you who are older
subscribers on this channel remember
that there was a subscribers video last
year I it was supposed to come out
somewhere after New Year's but I think
it took me some time to you know put
everything together so it came out I
think in February but the first thing
you will see in the description below
will be a link to the subscribers video
and in that video I asked you to send me
a photo or a short video the doesn't
really matter both works of you teaching
someone how to play chess it doesn't
have to be like the rules or like
anything really long I just take anyone
who doesn't play chess like your brother
your sister your mother father
grandmother boyfriend girlfriend wife
husband really anyone who doesn't play
chess and try to get to them interested
interests that way
well now we get more chess players into
into this entire thing and we make the
world a better place of course and you
send me a photo either you will be I
don't know teaching maybe your sister
how to play chess and you will make a
nice photo of it or you will make a nice
video maybe a short video just think a
few things but if
you're interested how it's done again I
say check out the subscribers video the
first thing you will see in the
description below and then you can maybe
write what's going on and then I will
also include that I don't know if I will
be using the same format as I did in my
previous subscribers video but maybe
maybe something similar feel free to
also suggest what kind of music we
should use for the for the next
subscribers video maybe maybe you're
into creating music so maybe you want to
create the music that would be used in
the next subscribers video I don't know
and also I don't know I might even let
someone else edit it I don't know I must
really I really hate editing that's why
I never edit any of my videos but for
that video I'm gonna have to do some
editing but well you know those are
little things we're gonna get back to
that after after I receive all of them
so the next thing you will see in the
description below
after this subscribers video will be an
email that you can use to send me those
photos or videos last year we had a case
where well I received a lot of viruses
and a lot of well stuff you shouldn't
send someone over the email but as all
of that goes through you know an
anti-virus it's it's really not gonna do
any harm so you know just send me send
me normal stuff that's basically all I'm
asking you I do hope I don't know stuff
you will try try and do this as we are
all in this together you know to promote
chess and I really hope it's gonna be a
very nice video because that the last
year's video is really beautiful really
it's it's wonderful to see so many so
many people from different countries
different cultures different languages
are all well basically speaking the same
language that is chess so that's it
about that like I said first thing in
the description below the subscribers
video from last year second thing will
be the email you can use to send me your
materials now getting back to this it's
it's a puzzle by Paul Banco
it's a mate in two by white so white
delivers mate in two
you can also do it of course in more
moves white is a winning however you put
this but it's important to do it in two
moves so feel free to pause the video
here check out the puzzle and you know
try to try to work things out I'm just
gonna have a nice simple water till we
you know decide on that
alright for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations
and for those of you who are perhaps who
perhaps had a crazy day like me and just
wanna you know chill for Christmas the
idea is well there are a couple of ideas
if you go night capture some d-6 yes
you're delivering a discovered check
also the bishop is protecting the night
everything is cool the night is also
protecting the rocker but after the shot
we for there's really no way to deliver
checkmate whatever you do in one move
and you basically have to solve it in
two moves so that's not it you will be
able to do it after Queen captures on c3
and then okay you can capture the rook
sure that will be checkmate or if roll
captures here then Knight d4 will also
be checkmate but that's the point this
rook always has to be here at the keep
and I have to keep an eye on the d4
square and also you will not be able to
deliver any Knight f4 checkmate as then
you will block your own dark square
bishop another thing you can try instead
of knife captors on d6 if you found a
look at the e5 check also interesting
but after D captures an e5 again there's
no way to deliver mate in one move the
pawn is now controlling both squares
that the knight can go to and after
something like Knight to c5 yes it's
it's a very nice move but you will not
be delivering checkmate in one move King
can still move to d6 and only then after
a bit of captures that this will be
checkmate so those are the two things
that don't work what actually works and
the congratulations to everyone who
found this you really you know you
really are having the greatest of
Christmases it's Queen to c5 seems like
seems like a crazy move but you there
will always be a crazy move if it's a
puzzle to solve
and whenever there's a cool puzzle of
course it will not start with a capture
so what do you do here
the threat of course is Queen captures
and if you just make a silly move let's
say we move the pawn then Queen captures
this will be checkmate and they are if
you don't do it if you play like rook
captures Queen then again you get Knight
to d4 and this will again be checkmate
because the rook is no longer
controlling the d4 square and aside from
making a silly move or capturing the
Queen you could play virtual captures
here but now the difference is you can
actually play Knight to f4 checkmate
because it doesn't matter that the
knight is blocking the bishop as the
Queen is controlling the entire fifth
rank so that's basically the solution to
the puzzle really amusing that basically
a lot to this video but okay
Quincy five very nice and then it's all
over whatever black makes whatever move
black makes it's checkmate yeah so
that's the solution I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you had you know
great great Christmas and that you will
you know have every other day that will
be great as well tomorrow we are
continuing normally as we have the start
of the world rapid and blitz
championship it's gonna last I think
from 26th up until New Year's so we will
be enjoying that do join this entire
plan of mine to promote chess worldwide
and you know grab anyone and then teach
them to play chess just a little or or
maybe just try to get them interested
and then send me a photo or a video of
you doing it so that's that's all so
also interesting fact if you're
interested this is actually not a
Christmas hat it's actually a decoration
for the chair you know as here you can
just see it I didn't have a hat so you
could use it as a head if like you
really had if you had a really big head
but it's actually a decoration for the
chair you know to make Christmasy
Christmasy feeling sir I do hope you
enjoyed that little fact as well I would
like to thank Reno's
naraku tell krishnan UNIFEM Liang and
Nathaniel Pomeroy David Sanford and
miroslav bow back for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
starting the world blitz and rapid
championship in Moscow and also join the
the 2019 subscribers video by sending me
materials and also promote chess thank
you all and I will see you soon